[MUSIC PLAYING]
DOMINIC PREUSS:
Thank you, everyone.
My name is Dominic Preuss.
I look after our storage
database and capacity products
on Google Cloud platform.
I'm very excited today,
day three of the conference
which has been an
incredible conference,
to talk about how Google
has reinvented databases
and how those people coming
to Google Cloud Platform
can learn from us and take
advantage of the things
that we've learned.
So let's start talking about
the early days of Google.
People often say that
Google was late to cloud.
And while Google got into the
public cloud space in 2014,
Google has been running one
of the largest, private cloud
infrastructures for
almost 15 years.
And so even though
we've only been
working with our external GCP
customers for about four years,
we have 15 years of
learnings and technologies
we develop over time that
really have made it possible
for us to work with
these GCP customers
and enable things that they
haven't been able to do before.
So the purpose of this
talk is to take you
through Google's journey, see if
that maps to some of the things
that you're seeing as customers
in some of the journeys
you're going through.
And then we'll talk to one of
the customers that has gone
through this journey on GCP.
And then we'll
take a little time
to do a demo because all
good talks have a demo.
For those 15 years,
Google was internally
building technologies
that are use cases.
And we were hitting
use cases that
were a little bit different
than the rest of the world
was seeing.
So we would develop
these technologies,
and we wanted to push
these technologies out
to the outside world.
But prior to Google
Cloud Platform,
the only way for us to do
this was via white papers.
And so we published
lots of white papers.
So if you go back to 2002, we
published the original Google
File System white paper.
So this was what we had learned
running a distributed storage
system that we could push
back to the rest of the world.
We filed that with Bigtable.
And we're going to talk a
little bit about the origins
of Bigtable in this talk.
And then that spawned
the NoSQL movement
and a lot of the
things that have
happened in the H-based space
and in the Hadoop space.
Fast forward a little bit,
we published the Spanner
in F1 papers in 2012.
And then finally, we got into
the Google Cloud Platform time.
So now we were actually able
to take these technologies
that we had developed and
that we'd offered back
to the community
as white papers,
and offer them as actual
cloud services, public cloud
services.
So BigQuery is the
same technology that
was in the Dremel white paper.
Cloud Bigtable is
the same technology
that was in the Cloud
Bigtable white paper.
And then Cloud Spanner is the
combination of the technology
that we talked about in
the Spanner and F1 papers.
And so really we've
been able to take
these 15 years of experience
and then leverage those
as we've gotten into
the public cloud
to help customers build
new and exciting things.
So with that, I'm very
excited to bring up
Chris Taylor to the stage.
Chris is an early Googler.
He was one of the original
authors of Spanner
and as our tech lead for
all structured storage
products, not only
Google Cloud Platform,
but at Google in general.
Welcome, Chris.
[APPLAUSE]
So now I get to embarrass Chris.
So I really want to
start at the beginning.
Because one of the
things that people
often ask us about is why?
Why did Google have to
build it's own technology?
So first thing for
Chris, so why did Google
build its own database
technologies instead
of using what was available?
CHRIS TAYLOR: Well, so I think
the thing Google has always
had to deal with in
its history is scale.
A lot of our
applications have been
internet facing and
internet search,
and they just sort of scale
with the size of the internet.
And when you look at
the Bigtable paper,
it's full of URLs and
signals and there was really
nothing we could pull off
the shelf for internet scale.
DOMINIC PREUSS: And one of
the things that we learned
is that as we were
doing Bigtable
and as we were going
through the use cases,
I think one of the things
we saw was that it ended up
being a really good
tool for building
other things at Google.
CHRIS TAYLOR: Yeah, you
started to see us branching out
a little bit into more
things, many of them
were facing the internet.
They were Google customers and
Google has a lot of customers.
And so you find that
Bigtable is a good hammer
to use on all sorts of
problems that you come across.
And a good example of
this is sort of early
in my personal history.
When I joined Google, I worked
on a team called Google Alerts.
And Google Alerts
sends you email
when the web search
results change
for a query of your choice.
My first project Google was
learning to run Bigtable.
And the reason I was
learning to run Bigtable
was because we had a
MySQL back end that
was getting a little
uncomfortable at the number
of users, the number of
registered queries that we had.
And so I did a port.
DOMINIC PREUSS: Cool.
And one of the things
you like to say to me
is that in the
early days, we were
responsible for
indexing the internet
and that doesn't
really fit in MySQL.
And so you know, that's a
common problem that we had.
CHRIS TAYLOR: That's correct.
DOMINIC PREUSS:
And for the back,
we're having a little trouble
with the monitor screen.
So if you guys could bring
up the monitor screen,
that would be awesome.
Thank you.
So OK, that's kind of the
early days of Bigtable.
So kind of stepping forward, it
sounds like in the early days,
we were basically shipping
binaries in containers
just to teams to run
their own Bigtable.
And obviously today,
we run very differently
in a much more centralized way.
So kind of how did Google
make that decision?
Why did we move to
centralized services?
So how does that work?
CHRIS TAYLOR: Right.
So again, going back
to Google Alerts.
When I first started
with Bigtable,
the Bigtable team was
handing me a container
and I was meant to go run it.
I was on a two person team.
And I was on call for a Bigtable
cell which was entertaining.
I was sending mail
to the Bigtable team
every couple of weeks
because I needed
learn about the
command line flags
and I needed to figure
out how to do upgrades.
And I was behind on the
upgrades, let's be honest.
DOMINIC PREUSS: You're never
behind on anything, Chris.
CHRIS TAYLOR: So there
were a few things
that Bigtable saw in
moving to services here.
And there is to
that earlier point,
saving a lot of unnecessary
specialization and toil.
And there's a certain
agility that Bigtable
gets from controlling
its own release cycles,
being able to do upgrades
for its customers,
we get to change more
things than we would expect.
This move to services was
a painful thing for us.
The first versions
didn't work that well.
There was a loss of
control for the teams.
The service didn't necessarily
get immediately better.
But this is something that we
iterated a lot on over time.
And over a couple of
years, because Bigtable
could see the
customer experience,
we could change things quickly.
Bigtable got a ton better.
100x improvements in throughput,
huge progress in tail latency,
cost reductions,
adding features.
When I came back to Bigtable
in 2009, creating a table
was a trivial thing.
You could just show
up, click, get table.
Really not that far
off from the experience
you get today in public
managed databases.
So overall, the move to services
was a huge success for Google.
It's very, very rare
for anyone at Google
to be running
their own database.
And really this experience,
making Bigtable into a service,
was such a success,
that when we looked
at an offering like Spanner that
we built a little bit later,
we designed that from
scratch to run as a service.
DOMINIC PREUSS: As
we went through,
we wanted to show a little
bit of historical photos.
So the prior photo was actually
when the internal Spanner
service went to GA.
You saw Chris was the
tall guy in the back.
And then this was actually
one of the first outages.
So the team is working
with a customer who's
the smiling guy in the
blue shirt, who is actually
debugging the problems
with the team.
So the pros and cons of
centralized services.
So we've talked a little
bit about Bigtable
and some of the things learned.
So why build Spanner?
And I think the
question that I always
get is, why did we think
Spanner was possible, right?
CAP Theorem, all
these other things.
So why did we think that this
is something we could do?
CHRIS TAYLOR: So
I'd like to say it's
that we're visionaries
of some kind,
but it's not really very true.
Instead, we were kind of
dragged to the realization
that NoSQL and
eventual consistency
weren't working for all
of the Bigtable customers.
Google changed a lot
over this period.
We were getting into
things like Gmail, Google+,
personalized search, and
consistency was starting
to really matter to
some of those things.
At the same time, Google's
SQL Native Ads and Payments
businesses were growing in
size, growing in sophistication.
They were using MySQL,
and it was frankly
struggling to keep up.
We were sharding it really
heavily, needing to re shard
it from time to time.
And then also we
were seeing this sort
of steady drumbeat
of serious bugs, even
the occasional major outage.
Which were basically caused by
eventual consistency ambushing
developers.
And so sitting in
the Bigtable team,
we were seeing applications
building consistency,
transactions, indexes,
and even SQL engines
as layers on top of Bigtable.
And we came to the realization
that the hard problems
we were avoiding
weren't gone, they
were just pushed to customers.
And so while Spanner in its end
state looks big and ambitious,
it didn't sort of
spring fully-formed out
of someone's head.
It was the next thing we
could do based on what
we were seeing built around us.
I would also say that Spanner
was an inflection point for us
in technical
infrastructure at Google.
It was when we decided our job
was to take on as much storage
complexity as we could handle.
And this was really so that
Google's many, many businesses
could move faster and do more.
The more we took on, the more
they could not have to do.
And we're really not done
with this process either.
One of the exciting things
about coming to work every day
is that I can see the
impact that Spanner
has on Google's
business and I know
there's just more we can do
and more that we're working on.
DOMINIC PREUSS: Cool.
This is actually one
of my favorite photos,
so why don't you give the
background in this photo?
CHRIS TAYLOR: Sure.
So this was early
days at Spanner.
We had a big nightly test
that ran on 40 or 50 machines.
We called it systest.
Sort of randomized,
really stressful thing.
We ran one copy of it
at night at that time.
And this was our
board of post-it notes
to show how we were doing.
So this little arrow points
to the week we were on.
So that would would
have been a Wednesday.
It was kind of a
rolling list thing.
So every day I would
put up a post-it.
It was an x or a check.
If it was an x, you can
see little marks in pen
for what went wrong that day.
DOMINIC PREUSS: A
lot of x's on there.
CHRIS TAYLOR:
Fortunately, we've exited
this phase of our history.
And we now run significantly
more testing every night
and it comes up a lot greener.
But it was fun.
DOMINIC PREUSS: See?
Spanner starts the same
way everything else does.
So as we talked
about, we've been
doing this for about 15 years.
We've talked about
Bigtable and Spanner.
And so what are the
things that we've
learned kind of running
this centralized service
over the last 15 years
that we think is--
that you found surprising
that you kind of keep
in the back of your pocket when
you think about these problems?
CHRIS TAYLOR: Sure.
So I think the main
thing that I take away
is an appreciation for just how
hard it is to develop and scale
a managed database service.
You know, I don't know
if you can see my hair.
I cut it short
when I was getting
ready for this presentation.
There was a lot
more gray in it now
than there is in the picture you
can see me of me on the board
here.
DOMINIC PREUSS: We've documented
your hair turning gray
through these processes.
CHRIS TAYLOR: Yes.
So it's been over a decade
since the Bigtable paper,
a decade of developing
Spanner but half
a decade since the paper.
And when you get
into the code, you
can see that while the
20,000 foot architecture is
the same as what we
documented there,
almost all the
code is different.
There's a lot more of it.
And we've learned
a lot about why
simpler alternatives to what
we do are just catastrophic.
And this is really an
under-rated benefit
of using a high scale service
like Spanner or Bigtable.
We've found that the only
way you can scale a Spanner
or Bigtable 10x in
customers, bytes, or QPS,
is to decrease outages per
customer, byte or QPS by 10x.
And anything else and the
number of failures you have just
grows and crushes you as
the service maintainer.
And that's the treadmill we're
on here in GCP databases.
But if you're a customer, you
likely are not scaling by 10x.
You probably aren't even
that big to begin with.
But you really feel the 10x
availability and reliability
that had to go into the
service during that time.
And that's just kind of
math working in your favor.
Generalizing from
it a little bit,
and you know I mentioned
this a little earlier,
Google's gained a lot of
flexibility and agility
by pushing complexity into its
first party database services
and taking it out
of applications.
That leaves the service
very challenging to build,
but if you can do the
work and get it right,
that amortizes really nicely
across all of your users.
DOMINIC PREUSS: It's
been really interesting.
Obviously you've
seen this evolution,
but Google with 500
engineers or 1000 engineers
is very different
than the 50,000.
And so running services
for 50,000 engineers
is very different scale problem.
Great.
And so now you and I have
been working together
on this journey into
the public cloud,
plenty of bumps along
the way, disagreements,
and collaboration.
But other things
that we've learned,
what are these learnings you
think apply to what we're now
seeing with our GCP customers?
And the journeys that we're
seeing from our GCP customers?
CHRIS TAYLOR: What
we're I think learning
is that there's not much to this
story that is Google specific.
Not every customer is building
a search engine, that's
only a couple of companies.
But every application has a
database or storage somewhere.
And the fundamentals of what
you want out of a database
really don't change.
You'd rather someone
else operate it.
You want it fast.
You want it reliable.
And you don't want to spend
your app's complexity budget
on limitations of your
database platform.
We also haven't talked
much about security,
but the list of requirements
for that gets longer every year
and that's on every
customer all the time.
DOMINIC PREUSS:
Apparently there's
this new thing called GDPR
that people are talking about.
That's new.
CHRIS TAYLOR: So we
put years of work
into being good at
that stuff, right?
These problems are
really near and dear.
And we work on them every day.
And we're excited to bring
some of those solutions
to Google Cloud.
Our best work, and really
this hearkens back to the why
did we build Spanner
stuff, is when
we can study what our
customers are trying to do,
what they're building.
And see what seems like
the right thing to build.
That's when we excel.
Cloud Platform's
a new era for us.
We've been doing the private
cloud thing for a long time.
But we're excited to work
with all of our customers
on a system we think is really
the future of public cloud
databases.
DOMINIC PREUSS: Awesome.
So Chris, thank you so much
for the historical context.
Let's give him a
round of applause.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Great, so that's about
what Google has learned.
And I think what's
most helpful for people
is here is the journey that
other customers have gone down.
So I'm very excited bringing
Daniel Spoonhower, a.k.a.
Spoons, CTO of LightStep,
to talk about their journey
into the cloud.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Great.
I'm excited to be here and
talk about a little bit of what
LightStep does, how
we built it, and how
we use some of the tools that
Dominic and Chris were just
talking about.
Right, that's me.
Almost everybody
does call me spoons.
I feel like that's the first
question everyone asks.
I used to be a Googler.
Now I'm a LightStepper.
And I guess I like to
build developer tools.
That's kind of what I've been
doing over and over again
in a bunch of different places.
So I wanted to start
with a Google paper
also, not one of the papers
that these guys mentioned.
This is a paper that
one of my co-founders
wrote almost 10 years ago now.
Was called Dapper and it talked
about Google's distributed
tracing infrastructure.
So Dapper was a
monitoring tool that
was built at Google to help
Google engineers understand
how requests would flow through
the system that had been built.
Each request would
hit potentially
thousands of machines,
thousands of services,
and all of that data was
then being aggregated
and flowed back to the user.
And understanding
where it was slow
could have been in
any of those services.
And this tool was
and continues to be
really critical in
building applications that
are composed from these
many different services.
Fast forward a couple of years.
Now it's not just
Google that is building
these kinds of systems.
And a lot of other
folks have started
breaking their applications
from monolithic entities
into smaller pieces.
Either microservices,
server-less,
all kinds of things like that.
But the point is that
once we've broken them up,
it's easier to build the
pieces independently.
It's easier to deploy
those pieces independently.
And it's easier to scale
them independently.
And that sounds great, right?
Maybe if you've
done this, you're
going to disagree that
everything's great.
And maybe if you can guess from
the picture, that maybe not
everything's great.
Does anyone know
Honest Status Page?
It's not a real status page.
It's like the status
page that you wish
your service providers had.
Anyway, this is one
of my favorite tweets.
"We replaced our monolith
with microservices
so that every outage can
be like a murder mystery."
And the thing is, breaking
up the application
was great in terms of
being able to build it.
But be able to understand it,
especially understanding it
from an end user's perspective,
just got a lot harder.
What we've done is take a story
which had one sort of actor
in a sense, and
we split that role
into a whole bunch of pieces.
And now if you were to read
any one of those rules,
it wouldn't make any sense.
You really need to see the big
picture and the whole story.
So how did Dapper work?
Well, roughly for every
request, for every search,
for every RPC between services,
Dapper captured timing data,
it captured logs,
and the connections
between those services.
This is a lot of data.
And if you're Google handling
a bajillion requests a second,
it's a lot a lot of data.
And so Dapper's
approach to this problem
was actually pretty
simple and effective.
It was just throw out
99.9% of the data.
Or maybe even 99.99% of the
data immediately without even
looking at it.
That might sound a little
bit crazy, but even
with that tiny sliver of data,
there's still a lot you can do.
So for example,
Google runs analyzes
of the samples it's taken to
understand and answer questions
like, on average, what was
causing web search to be
slow over the last week?
Was it query rewriting?
Was it image search results?
Was it a different
type of search result?
Or maybe it was just
good old network latency.
These are all
important questions
and they're critical to
prioritizing engineering work
and improving performance.
There's a tension,
though, between operating
at this kind of scale
and the features
that you might be able to
offer in other contexts.
So at LightStep, we took a
pretty different approach.
And I want to talk about that
from the perspective of one
of our customers.
So Lyft has deployed
LightStep and uses
LightStep to understand
their application.
They've built using a
microservice architecture.
And they use this really
cool service mesh technology
called Envoy to
basically proxy requests
between those microservices.
And one of the
things that you can
do with that that's
pretty awesome
is that meant that we could
integrate really quickly
between Lyft and LightStep, and
get kind of instant visibility
into how requests were
passing from the app all
the way through all of their
different microservice systems.
So how does LightStep
differ from Dapper?
The short answer
is that LightStep
looks at all of the data.
So for Lyft, that means
we analyzed more than 100
billion RPCs every day.
That's something
like tens of millions
of microservice
requests every second.
And we think if you're
a Lyft engineer,
your firefighting
an outage, you want
to understand what's
happening, every single one
of those requests
could potentially
be important to you.
And so we want to
make sure that we
have all of that data
there available to you
to answer those questions.
To do this, we had to take
a pretty different approach
to what was done in Dapper.
And we had to put a lot
of thought and effort
into building a really
efficient system for processing
all of this data.
This is part of our team.
We've taken what we've learned
from Dapper, what we've
learned from using and building
other kinds of monitoring
tools.
And we're trying to take
all of that experience
and bring it to our mission
to help developers understand
application performance
as they adopt
these modern architectures
and platforms.
I would love to
talk about the work
that our team is
doing in building
these high volume, real time
event processing systems,
but you'll have to come
talk to me later about that.
I want to take a minute and talk
about the parts of LightStep
that are not super high volume,
real time event processing
systems.
We still need to
deploy services.
store our timing data,
trace data, lot of other
stuff persistently.
A whole bunch of stuff that
was critical, but not unique
to our business
and to our product.
And as LightStep
got off the ground,
we had to make a lot of choices.
Where do we build?
Where do we buy?
Where do we use open source?
Where do we reinvent the
wheel or hopefully not?
So I want to tell
you a little story.
We're a monitoring service.
Maybe you're
wondering what tools
we use to monitor our
monitoring service.
And of course, there's
a bunch of them.
LightStep is one of those.
So we operate a bunch
of different instances
of LightStep.
One of those we call
Meta and Meta's job
is just to keep watch on
the rest of LightStep.
And at the time of this story,
Meta, like the other instances
included a Cassandra
deployment that
was used to store
some low frequency
information to low
frequency time series data.
And we kept running into
problems with resource use,
some of the instances
were booming.
We had some problems
with the way
that we had deployed it
on top of Kubernetes.
Which maybe you
can imagine where
this is going a little bit.
But roughly, what
that all led to
is some persistent and
reoccurring corruption
in the underlying SSTables.
And this, in fact, led
to one of the worst
outages we've ever experienced.
Luckily, it wasn't in a
customer facing environment.
But it still felt pretty bad to
have one of our own instances
down for quite a while.
And a lot of
engineering time went
into mitigating the problem.
I think days of engineer's
time just to get us back
where it was working again.
And we were not out of
the woods by any means
because a lot of
these configurations
were also being used in
our other environments
and they just hadn't
hit these problems yet.
So we quickly did
some evaluation
to look at some other options.
And we ended up with Spanner.
Maybe not surprising in the
context of where we are today.
But it actually I
think took us less work
to migrate from where we were
onto Spanner than it would have
taken us to build the
expertise and just fix
the deployments that we had in
production live at the time.
I think it's really
important to look back
at the choices we've
made and understand
what we could have done
better and what we learned.
In this case, I think it
really reinforced me for me
that you can't overestimate
the engineering hours that
will go into understanding
and maintaining
a distributed storage system.
Again, this is all hindsight.
I feel really obvious.
But where we were, we were
just making decisions really
fast as a small company.
But I think this is one of the
instances that I look back on.
And whenever we have a choice
to use a hosted service,
this is the kind of
thing I think about.
Because with something
like Spanner,
I don't think about the
human operational costs
and I'm confident that we're in
control, that we can scale it
up as we need, and
we can make choices
about what other technology we
want to use to complement that.
So if you kind of look under
the hood at LightStep today,
this is sort of
that in a nutshell.
Some secret sauce on the top.
And then Cloud Kubernetes
Cloud SQL Storage and Spanner.
Those are kind of the important
parts of what we have.
As a monitoring
tool, our customers
have pretty high expectations
for LightStep's reliability.
They depend on us to be there
even when their own services
are not working
so they can better
understand what's happening.
So as a service, it's
part of our brand
to be a reliable,
go-to kind of place.
We depend on other services
to help fulfill that promise.
And so I think to take
Spanner as an example,
I feel really good about
being in multiple regions now
and knowing that even fairly
large failures in terms
of a snow storm or
something like that
are not going to affect
the service that we provide
to our customers.
So to kind of
close up, if you're
adopting any of this
cool technology,
be it Kubernetes,
microservices, Cloud Functions,
whatever it is.
But you're having a
little bit of a hard time
understanding what's happening.
First, you can go talk
to some folks that
are right down at the end of
the hall, the Cloud Native
Computing Foundation.
They are incubating
Open Tracing.
Open Tracing is
an open source API
for getting data out
of an application
into a platform like LightStep.
They're also incubating
Envoy and a bunch
of other really cool stuff.
And then secondly,
of course I'd be
more than happy to talk
to folks about what
we're doing at LightStep.
I'm really excited about the
technology we're building
and the way that we can really
help push forward the way
that people are building
these kinds of applications.
So with that, I wanted to
thank everyone for listening.
I want to thank Dominic
and everyone at Google
for having me up here on stage.
[APPLAUSE]
DOMINIC PREUSS:
Thank you so much.
Great.
In these sessions, I always
find what's the most helpful
for GCP customers is to hear
the experience and learnings
from other GCP customers.
And so I really appreciate
Spoons being here to do that.
Now we've talked a little
bit about the past,
we've talked about the
present, so not we're
going to talk a little
bit about the future.
So I'm very excited to bring up
Deepti and Steve from the Cloud
Spanner team and they're
going to take you
through a preview of
some new things that
are coming in Cloud Spanner.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA:
Thanks, Dominic.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Deepti Srivastava.
I am the product manager
for Cloud Spanner.
Just to give a quick history,
I was also responsible
for launching
Spanner internally.
That photo was from my
phone that you saw earlier.
So my new Noogler project
was launching Spanner.
So I have some history in it.
And I'm joined by
Steve Middlekauff
who is a senior engineer
in the Spanner team.
And he's going to show us
a few cool things that we
have coming out.
So I talked about this
in my talk yesterday,
but basically as we heard
from Chris and Dominic,
we've been building
Spanner for a long time.
And of course, the
history of databases
is 30 plus years long.
So we could have
added features like--
there was a ton of features that
we could have added and exposed
to our cloud customers,
but we really
wanted to be deliberate about
what we offer on the Cloud
Platform to our
customers based on what
they're looking for, right?
So we added multi-region,
et cetera last year.
And then there's two really
highly anticipated features
that I get asked about a lot
that we're here to show today.
This is not a promise
of timelines or sort
of announcements of
the feature launch,
it's more about what
we've been working on
and what we hope to have
in the next few months.
Before we get into it, we also
launched the import export
functionality for Cloud Spanner
which was the top feature
demand last week.
And we demoted it
also yesterday.
So but today, I want to
talk about the things we're
working on that we
think are super cool.
So what Steve has here
is our UI console.
If you aren't
familiar with Spanner,
this is the UI that we have
and we start with the instance
page on our UI.
Cloud Spanner instances are like
in other situations clusters.
So basically, this is our
unit of replication topology
and instance in isolations.
So you can have multiple
databases inside a Cloud
Spanner instance.
So in this case, we're looking
at a DML demo database.
So yeah, the first functionality
we're going to talk about
is DML, which is doing inserts,
updates and deletes in SQL.
So just to be clear, you have
the ability to mutate data,
to insert, update,
delete through the API,
but we didn't have this
DML capability in SQL
and now we are working
on releasing it soon.
So we're excited
to talk about that.
So in this case,
our demo database
is a ticket info database.
And as can see, the
schema on the side,
it has a count event, ticket,
and all those kinds of tables.
Fairly standard
relational database.
And we also have two indexes on
the event table, event by date
and event by multi-event ID.
So now let's actually
query the database.
Now, this is something
you can do today.
So you can go to
the query console
and you can actually
type in queries.
And you can get the
results right there.
So Steve typed in a
query to get information
for all of the events
in the event table.
And as you can see, we
have no multi-event ID
set in this table.
So let's look at the explain
plan, again, something
we have today.
Where you can look
at the SQL explain,
as you can see it's
using the index
to be efficient about
fetching this data.
So now, what if we wanted
to change the multi-event ID
to say, Cloud Next
for all events
that happened as
of Tuesday, which
is when Cloud Next started.
So we have an update
query, update where.
And voila, we have a DML
query that completed.
So let's look at
the explain plan.
And as you can see, in
our explain plan now
we have applied
mutations so we're
supporting explain in
the DML case as well.
So let's look at
what we actually
did so we're not
faking this out,
like the data
should have changed.
It's a live demo.
And it should say multi-event
ID for all the events
that are as of Tuesday.
And as you can see,
I wasn't lying.
We can actually make
DML statements work.
Now the cool thing
about this is that you
can do this for
petabyte scale databases
or very, very small databases.
And you can do it right
in the query console.
But of course,
when we release it,
we're going to have it
in our API in the UI
and also through
our JDBC drivers.
So just again, to be clear,
we do have a JDBC driver
right now, which is
read-only because we
didn't have DML statements.
And when we launch, we will
have the JDBC driver as well.
And we plan to have ORM
support as we go along
Spring Boot, hibernate,
et cetera, once we
have this functionality.
So hopefully I answered
number two of the most
frequently asked
feature requests.
Now let's look at
another feature
that I'm super excited
about that we're also
planning to launch soon.
This is called the Query
Statistics feature.
So we're back at
our instance page.
And as you can see, it's
the same demo instance
that has the same ticket
information as before,
the same schema.
Now, as we enter the
instance in this case,
now we have a new
tab, Query Stats.
And if you click into
the Query Stats tab,
you can see that we are
basically showing you
all the queries that
took up the most
resources in the last,
in this case, minute.
So we have multiple
buckets in which
we aggregate this information,
one minute, 10 minute, one
hour, 24 hours.
So hopefully it
gives you a good view
of how things are behaving
over that period of time.
But we're most interested in
the last minute for right now.
So this is sorted by the
top 10 queries by CPU.
Let's click into the first one.
So now we have an
info pane panel there
that shows us more information
about this particular query
that's been taking the most
CPU in the last one minute.
So it's been taking
261 CPU seconds.
And as you can see
in our info panel,
there is more information
like average latency,
rows scanned, rows
sent, et cetera.
So in this case, you can
see that the rows scanned
and the rows sent
are the same, which
means that the query isn't
doing any aggregations,
or filters, or joins.
And if you look at
the query text, which
is right there so
you can actually
inspect that particular
query as well,
you can see that it's not
doing any of those things.
The intuition is accurate here.
One thing to talk about
here is that the query
is using a parameterized value.
So it's using bind parameters.
And this is actually a useful
thing to do in general, both
because it helps you with
performance and latency
because the query engine
can then have an opportunity
to cache this query
plan so that you
don't have to rebuild the
query plan every time you
run the query.
And if you saw the
statistics earlier,
the query is actually run about
150,000 times last minute,
but it didn't have to rebuild
the whole query plan each time
even though the account ID
value could be different.
So it will obviously
help it perform better.
But also, it helps
with collecting
these kinds of stats, right?
Because the engine understands
that this is the same query
that you're running over
and over and over again.
So now let's look at another
query that's more interesting.
So this query took
34 CPU seconds
and so much less than
the previous one.
And it ran only 1,000 times.
But in this case, the row
scan and send are different.
And obviously, that means
it's doing something
more interesting with
fetching the data
and then returning
it to the user.
So look, we have the
query opened right
there so we can take a look.
And what it's doing is
it's fetching the seating
capacity for all the venues.
And Steve is moving
faster than I can talk.
But in case you wanted to debug
the query as it was running
in either development
or production,
you would want to open
it and run it and see
what it does, right?
So you can click on
a button right there
and in that Query Stats page.
It will open this
SQL API query API
and you can actually
inspect the query that you
can run it as Steve ran.
And you can see that we have
a Beijing Stadium category
1 and category 2 both
have 6,000 seats.
And if we look at the
query explain plan
because we want to see what is
it doing, why is it doing it?
You can see that it's
applying all these filters
and doing a cross apply
hash aggregate join.
So the idea here is
that as you're both
developing your
system and as you're
looking at your system
and its performance,
you can inspect right there
what the thing is doing.
And this is a plan for
this particular invocation
of the query, but it
can give you an idea of,
let's say, it's
taking a long time
and you want to see is it
using the right index or not?
Or do I need to create an index?
All those kinds of things you
can see by quick inspection.
So these are some of the many
features we're working on.
If you have feedback
for us, I'll
be here as well after the
talk to take your feedback
and answer your questions.
But hopefully this was
as exciting for you
as it's been for us.
So thank you so
much for listening.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
DOMINIC PREUSS: Thank
you, Deepti and Steve.
I am so excited to get this out.
I know developers
have been asking
for this for many months.
And so I look forward to when
they get this in their hands.
Now one of the things
that I wanted to do,
because we have been talking
about all of our databases,
is give you a quick
recap of all the things
that we've been
announcing here at Cloud
Next over the last three days.
So first of all,
Cloud Firestore.
So we announced this a
while ago in Firebase.
So it was part of
the Firebase console.
So now Cloud Firestore
is available to you
with the UI embedded into the
Google Cloud Platform Cloud
Console.
It introduces Data Store Mode.
So what this means is customers
that are using Datastore
can now use the same
API with no changes
and take advantages of
the new features that
are in Cloud Firestore.
And so what this means
is that now all Datastore
customers will be
automatically migrated
over the next period
of time with no code
changes, no
interruption of service,
so that all those
Datastore customers
can take advantage of
all the new features that
are in Cloud Firestore.
So we're very
excited about this.
Second of all, as
we've been migrating
all of these large
enterprise customers.
So we've talked
about Target earlier,
we've previously talked
about HSBC and Home Depot.
As these enterprise
workloads are coming over,
there's lots of existing
applications that require
things like SAP and Oracle.
So we've talked a lot
about our relationship
with SAP and all the
things that we're
doing to provide an
amazing experience for SAP
customers and GCP.
And now we can bring
those Oracle workloads
to GCP via our
partners, specifically
Accenture and some of the
other strategic partners
that we'll be announcing
the service with.
Cloud Bigtable.
So one of the biggest ask for
Cloud Bigtable was the ability
to replicate the data.
So this had been
previously in beta,
and it is now launched
to general availability
with new improvements
for the SLA
on availability that
comes along with that.
Cloud Spanner.
We recently announced
import export, which
is now available to everyone.
And then throughout
the rest of the year,
we'll be launching
the DML regrade JDBC
drivers and Query Statistics
that Steve and Deepti just
showed us.
And to make sure that we talk
about all of our products
and make sure everyone
understands the portfolio
and the breadth of products
that we offer our customers.
So Cloud Memory Store is our in
memory managed Redis offering.
So if you have Redis
workloads that you'd
like to bring to
Google Cloud Platform
and have us manage
for you, we're
very excited that
this is in beta.
This is another hotly requested
feature from our developers.
Cloud Data Store and Firestore,
so that beta goes out.
So if you have document database
workloads, especially if you're
developing web or
mobile applications,
this is an amazing
product that we're
very excited to get
more tightly integrated
into the GCP experience.
Cloud Bigtable, for our low
latency, scalable wide column
stores, there's a number of
talks about Cloud Bigtable.
But if you have those
H-space workloads or some
of the Cassandra workloads that
we'll talk about in my database
migration talk, that
is available for people
to provide that workload.
Cloud SQL, so managed
MySQL and Postgres.
So we introduced Postgres
a little while ago and now
that's in general availability.
Again, incredible demand
and people asking for
managed Postgres.
So now that that's
there, we're very
excited to see all the
applications that people
are going to build with that.
And then Cloud Spanner.
So our scale out
mission critical
RDBMS that we just talked about.
Really provides a portfolio
of first party services.
Now, there's lots of
other amazing solutions
that are out there.
So we're very excited
with our partnerships.
And so Redis Labs is
running a managed Redis
offering on top the platform.
Mongo DB with Mongo DB Atlas.
We have a wonderful
Elasticsearch service
through our partner at Elastic.
And we have per
second SQL server
images that you can run on GCP.
And then we just talked about
our SAP and Oracle offerings.
So depending on what you happen
to be running on premise,
whatever that might
be or wherever
you're running your
current workloads,
we have a set of offerings
either through Google Cloud
Platform or through our
partners to meet those needs.
And with that,
thank you very much.
I appreciate your time today.
Please enjoy the rest
of the conference
and feel free to come
find us after the session.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]